- All right, well, I think we are back.
And so we had a little bit
of technical difficulties,
and sometimes it might
happen in the internet,
but Ernest, you were going
through your explanation,
and you're talking about
kind of how at Morehouse,
we were able to work with
these tech companies,
and you were able to discovered the magic
of software engineering,
which I experience something very similar,
when I first learned that you could code,
and make almost anything in the world.
I have one question similar to
where Delia's narrative went, which was,
when you applied to Morehouse,
how much were finances an issue?
What did financial aid look like?
Or what did the debt situation look like?
And what made you confident
that it was worth the
investment.
We might've lost Ernest.
So (chuckle) let me move to Madison,
Madison, I'll ask you the same question,
I ask Delisha and Ernest, which is,
how did you think about it when
you were leaving high school
college, right, for you?
If so, what college, what major,
how did money factor into it?
- Yeah, so I'll give you a little bit of
personal information about myself.
I'm actually a first generation American,
so my parents were adamant
about me kind of fulfilling
that dream for them going to college,
and I knew that was definitely, (chuckle),
the only choice I had,
but I can tell you, I guess,
thinking about my 16 year
old self it was terrifying,
to essentially perceive the job market,
as something I'm doing
for the rest of my life.
You know, of course that
that myth was dispelled
during my college years,
it's not necessarily
one thing I have to do
for the rest of my life,
but being 16, that's what
I thought it would about.
I'm like, wow,
I really have to pick something
and I have to just stick
with it for my life, (chuckle),
and thought haunted me for awhile.
So before high school,
my parents certainly
wanted me to be a doctor,
a 100%, like they were convinced
I was going to be a doctor.
They're like, "Yep, you're
gonna work at the same hospital
your father does, and
you're gonna do this."
And I'm like, okay, you know,
your parents, you kinda just go with it.
But as I progressed and
even in middle school,
I just knew I loved art,
and as much as House and a
bunch of other doctors shows
interest me and I loved
working with people,
I liked art more,
and that was something
that I needed to realize
in high school,
and I'm just like, okay, like,
16 year old me logic was
if I was gonna do something
for the rest of my life, I
need to like it, (laughs),
So I started researching
what I can do in art,
and I think that just opened
up my mind to the possibilities
of where I can go and what I can do,
and design being such a broad
subject and abroad major.
I can go into several different things,
which I'll definitely go into
being like more multi-faceted
a little bit later, but in
terms of picking college,
I was looking around and
there were some local ones,
I'm originally from New Jersey,
so I was looking at Rutgers,
Montclair, Seton Hall,
all these state schools.
Didn't like,
Ernest, didn't really know
about much about HBCU at all.
But I had a friend whose older
brother who did go to attend
Howard,
and he just came back
and there was something
just different about him.
I don't know what it was,
I just my colleague he
seems a lot more confident,
he seems, you know, I don't
know it was like an aura almost,
and I was like, hey, let me just ask.
And I think asking those questions
and seeking that guidance
and help from him really
helped me in order to
make my college decision,
and I was fortunate enough to
take a weekend trip down to DC
and just step on campus and
really feel the environment.
And I do suggest for
my students out there,
try to, if you can, if
you have the means to,
and the ability to go to the universities,
that you are interested in,
and feel, you know, ask questions,
stop the student, students
like to talk (chuckle),
ask them, hey, what do you
like about your university?
What would you like to see improved?
What's your favorite part?
And on Howard's campus,
I was able to just talk to so many people,
and I'm like, wow, these
people are so cool,
and, (chuckle), I wish
there was more technicality
and a rhyme and reason to my story,
but it was really just
because I love that campus,
that our department was great.
A lot of people on that campus
had the same interests as me
and yeah, that's pretty much (chuckle),
my story on how I got here.
- Yeah, at least two big
takeaways I took from yours,
it is true.
Oftentimes you're 16 or 17 years old,
and you think what major you
choose or where you go to
college is gonna ... the die is cast
for the rest of your life.
But I think one of the narratives,
and we heard it with Delisha is that,
she thought she was gonna do one thing,
she did another thing,
and then now she's ended up in
a completely different thing
that as long as you're doing
things that are helping you
grow your general skills
and your thinking,
you might have a lot of options available.
Another thing that you
talked about, which is,
you asked a lot of questions,
you have that family
friend who went to Howard,
you asked them a lot of questions,
you went to the campus,
you asked a lot of questions.
So what I'm hearing is just the power,
of asking a lot of people,
a lot of questions.
We're going into it, I
have a ton of questions,
this is unusual,
how many questions we're
getting off of a social media.
So y'all are very popular,
more popular than I tend to
be what I'm just doing this,
by myself, but let me
jump into some of them.
So I have this question for Ernest,
Greatest American Daniel
asks, interesting username.
What is it like being a software engineer?
What do you do daily?
What's your day to day like Ernest.
(laughs)
- And can you hear me now?
Are we good?
- Yes, yes, we can.
- Great, great, great, great
love to answer that question,
being a software engineer
in the tech industry period,
but especially at Google
is one of the best jobs,
I think you can do in the world.
There's no other company
that you could come to,
get to work whenever you want,
I would say that, you know,
be surrounded by volleyball
courts, basketball courts,
swimming pools, video
games on every corner,
gourmet food and every cafe.
And the best part about
the food is it's all free,
like Google it's has a theory that like,
if they give their employees
every benefit possible,
and make sure that their
employees are the most relaxed,
and comfortable in the workplace,
then productivity will go up.
And I guess it's been
working because the Googles,
then making millions, if
not billions,(chuckle),
of impact in dollar.
A different engineer truly
looks as you come to the office
when you need, when you're ready to you.
Me personally, I'll go get some breakfast,
some nice bacon,
and cheese, sandwich maybe
depending on how I feel.
Check my email,
(indistinct) trying to
caught up with everything
with my manager,
and then I'm probably working on one of
maybe three or four projects.
So I started hacking away at some of them,
so I write some code by that time,
after like 30 minutes an
hour it's already lunchtime.
So I'll go get some lunch,
and lunch is amazing,
and Google has food for
every different background,
you think of food from
all parts of the world.
So if you want sushi, one
day, you can get sushi,
to fried chicken to a burger to a burrito.
And then in the afternoons
this is normally,
where you have a lot of meetings,
you're meeting with your team working,
make sure everyone is
getting the code on that,
it needs to be done.
And honestly, my day probably,
I'd probably get in the office at like 10,
and then I'll leave around four,
as long as I'm getting all my work done,
and it doesn't truly matter
what times of the day you're
working.
It's more, if you're
getting your product on,
when you said you're going to get it done.
Bottom line is the best job in the world,
I personally think.
- Well, I think you're
doing a great job recruiting
for Google.
I'm sure, I'm sure.
(laughing)
And I think by any objective measure,
Google is a very solid
employer to work for,
you know, just I'll back
question about the day-to-day.
I think that it's
intriguing for all of y'all,
and I'll add there's another
question from YouTube J McCall.
How did you guys know these
were the jobs you wanted,
and loved doing?
Maybe I'll go to you
first Delisha on this one,
one, if you wanna say anything
about your day to day,
that's always interesting,
what you're doing on a day-to-day basis,
but also, how did you
(indistinct) in on this one,
and where is it on that spectrum
of how much you love it?
- Right, I'll just add a little
tidbit about my day-to-day.
I will say I'm not at Google,
but it is great, like Google,
because I also get to
choose my own flexibility
and schedule as well, (chuckle).
So that's very awesome.
And then just as far as ... sorry,
what was the other question
is on my day-to-day?
- No, and how did you ...
well, one what's your day to day,
which it sounds like you also
get some flexibility in yours,
but also how did you
gravitate towards this?
You alluded to it a little bit,
you were in psychology, you
were interested in psychology,
which is objective a
very interesting field,
as a cybersecurity,
but then what made you do the leap?
Was there an opening?
And he was like, hey, that's kinda cool.
Let me just see what that is,
and you're like, I kind of enjoy this.
How did you fall into this
and realize you like it?
- It was actually by way of non-profit,
so for several years,
I actually served as a college
advisor but for organization,
nonprofit called College Advising Corps,
if you've heard of it,
we've actually worked
with college board before,
and I was serving in supporting
high school students,
like who were like me first
generation who had never family
that never went to college.
So I was supporting them with
the whole college process,
from college applications to essays,
to registering for the SAT or ACT,
giving them scholarship lists,
making sure they apply for scholarships,
getting ready for graduation.
If they weren't ready or
didn't wanna go to college,
then I was supporting them
through signing up for the
military or finding other
careers and opportunities,
that weren't related to college,
that will still provide
them for opportunities,
to make a change and
create generational wealth
for the family.
So from there I realized, okay,
I'm on the beginning
side of education where,
I'm supporting them and I'm
getting them to the door
to graduate from high school
and to get into college,
and I'm seeing them walk
through in their first year
of college and do all those great things.
But now I wanna support
them beyond that step,
how can I get on the other side,
which is higher education
and support them through the
actual college journey.
So that's when I actually
did some research,
I started searching,
I actually stumbled upon a
Science Technology Institute,
to be honest with you,
I thought I was like,
this is really exists,
this is one of those scam
jobs online, (chuckle),
because you can never be too careful.
It's kind of ironic that,
it's a top security college,
so even then I was a bit skeptical,
but I looked into it, do some research.
And then I realized that
they were a part of the best
cybersecurity leader in
industry, in the whole country.
And I said, okay, I'm
gonna give it a chance,
so although I didn't have
experience in higher education,
at that time I had never
worked as a student advisor
in the higher education
setting or for a college,
I applied.
Anyway, I stepped out on
faith out better on myself,
and I said, okay, I'm
gonna take this step,
I'm gonna bet on myself
and I'm gonna apply.
And that's just what I did,
I was afraid,
I was scared, (chuckle),
I was nervous, but I got a call back.
And several interviews later,
I landed the job and we're
not going on two years
in December,
and I haven't looked back since,
and I'm so thankful for the opportunity,
and I've learned so much
about cybersecurity.
It is so interesting,
and I'm just excited to teach
and inspire those out there
who are watching this
to want to defend again,
like our cyber war, because
cybersecurity is going to be...
and is a huge and critical
piece of our infrastructure,
in this country.
And it's something that
we're gonna need more people,
regardless of what major or
career path you come from,
regardless of your background,
you don't have to fit a mold,
there's no prototype of
what you need to look like,
or be, or like, or do
to join cybersecurity.
We want people from all walks of life,
whether you're into art and
you're really good at it,
or you're really good
at software engineering,
we need all of you from all
walks of life to come into the
world of cybersecurity,
to bring your diverse
perspectives and to help us
save the world.
(laughs)
- Yeah, I love it.
Very few jobs we can credibly
talk about saving the world,
and one, I was very entertained
by the notion that you thought
the cybersecurity college
might itself be some
type of efficient attack.
(laughing)
You might've,
but also I hear it in
your voice, the joy of ...
and this is I think education generally,
but being an advisor because
you get a multiplier effect
on your job,
you're helping other people
discover their journeys,
and then they will then
help save the planet.
Hopefully.
- Yes.
- Madison, what about on your side?
And I'll give a slightly
different flavor to the question,
which is, it's one thing
for you early on to say,
"Hey, you know, I like art
more than I like healthcare."
But there's another
thing where the education
and what you do in school
might be pretty different,
than what you end up doing for a job.
I've seen people who go
to school for one thing,
but then when they get
the job, they're like,
"Oh, this is what I have to
do on a day-to-day basis."
What was the transition from school,
which it sound like you
really enjoyed art school,
or the design aspects of it to work,
was it, as you were expecting,
was it better than expected?
Was it worse than expected?
How did you navigate that?
- I think this is a, a very,
very personal question,
to me, it was nothing like
my undergrad experience,
I can say, my internship
experiences and undergrad
reflect me being interested
in so many different things.
My freshman year I stayed
as a campus mentor,
on Howard's campus, just giving
tours, talking to people,
answering the same questions
that I asked as a senior,
being a freshman, I got it.
I got some answers, (chuckle).
So I was able to relay
that my sophomore year,
I was a accounting intern at,
NTTs government military
headquarters in Virginia,
which is totally outside of design.
And I can go on about that a days,
but my junior year,
I was able to intern with
New York fashion week,
which was something
I've never done before,
I ended up in New York for a weekend,
really just running around
and experiencing that,
and my senior year is when
I actually landed my dream
internship with NTT in
El Segundo, California.
I'm essentially working in
their entertainment sector,
which is right on the merge
of their merger with a timer.
And it was the craziest
experience (chuckle) ever.
And after college, I actually,
I received an offer from NTT,
but it wasn't necessarily
what I wanted to do,
more on the side of not in the location
where I wanted to in Texas,
I didn't really know anyone.
So I made the very unpopular
decision of declining that
offer, which is at the time I regretted,
all my friends were going
to these major places,
and that was still kind of home,
so I was like, ah, what's going on?
(chuckle)
That's when I decided to start
small with IG building up,
you know, some clients I had in college,
as well as some local businesses,
and really just honing
in on my craft a bit more
while working kind of a ...
there's a term they use in LA,
when actors are waiting
for their big break,
but they're kinda just in-transit,
I had an in-transit job
and didn't really like it,
but I knew design was what I wanted to do,
so I kept working,
I actually ended up interning
last year with Pentagram,
for those who are familiar
with the design in the world,
it's actually the largest
independently design firm
in the world.
I worked under Elle
Parker and Michael Bierut,
and busted my butt for
about a year, (laughs),
learning more and growing
and understanding.
And some nights (indistinct)
just gonna test,
I stayed up until like two
o'clock in the morning,
learning things and trying to get better,
and a couple of months ago,
I accepted this job with CNN,
which is my dream job.
So my path is definitely a winding road,
and not a straight path whatsoever.
So to answer your question,
no, it was nothing,
like what I expected or what I imagined.
- You know, there's this theme
that I'm getting from all
of y'all and this is true
in my journey as well that,
there's a lot of things
that maybe your college,
and your major might've helped you with,
but at the end of the day,
a lot of it is in each of your journeys,
you're asking questions,
you're constantly learning,
doing more and more things.
There's a bunch of questions
I'm getting around grades
and test scores.
For example, Calvin Tran says,
"Do grades determined if
you're going to be successful."
Alejandro Garcia,
"Can your scores on the
SAT or ACT determined,
which careers may be good for you?"
Let's see, there's another question.
Lower, I think someone was asking,
I think they've been discouraged,
for going into certain fields
maybe because they don't feel
I have the grades or the test scores.
What advice do you have
for students who are ...
because obviously when
you're in high school
and a lot of college,
your grades and your test
scores seem to matter a lot,
how do y'all think about that?
And what have you seen in your own lives
or people around you, maybe
I'll randomly select Ernest,
you go first, (chuckle).
- Yeah, (clearing throat).
I came from a family where
education was the foundation
of everything.
Like we couldn't do ...
my sister and I did theater growing up,
we were in karate with different sports.
We couldn't do extracurriculars,
if we weren't tight on our grades,
and our parents have your
praises all the time,
it'd be got honors roll,
honor roll or high honors.
And sending that foundation
early in our lives really put us
on a great academic path all
the way up into college, right?
We were always striving to be
in honor classes, AP classes,
and then in college
and the honors program,
and Dean's list and all that.
So I will always say it is
important to have a strong
educational basis because that
actually helps you also have
the right discipline with
everything else that you do
in life.
Just because you're
working at a job at Google,
as a software engineer,
and you're not getting
A's and B's and C's,
does not mean that
you're not (indistinct).
You're still gonna be graded, (chuckle),
on how well you're performing
at your job as well.
So everything is always
associated with one another,
that being said, companies like Google,
don't ask you require you to
have a certain GPA to come
work or even apply.
And I actually encourage all students,
no matter what you pay, they have,
or what situation they're in
to always apply to all these
companies,
because we need to always have
people from a bunch of
different backgrounds,
with a bunch of different
thought processes, right?
But I still strongly recommend,
that you focus in on your grades,
get those good grades 'cause
good grades can lead to a lot
of different things.
So you're about to bring up earlier,
I'm a little worried about
talking about a little bit about
affording college,
college is expensive,
what we talk about right.
But the thing is,
especially with great
academics and make helps
get you scholarships,
so you can actually afford college.
The other thing also
with tech industry jobs,
if you guys don't know,
I mentioned earlier,
I internet Google and internship
is when you actually go
leaves, I mean you don't leave school,
but like during the summer,
when you're normally on summer break,
you're actually going to work
at these different companies.
And these internships are actually paid,
Google's internship alone on the summer,
you probably can make somewhere
between 12 to $15,000.
That's a lot of money that can you,
you can take and put right
back into your education.
So that's why I'm very big
on students making sure that
they're staying strong in their academics,
not so that they can get a 3.5
so they can get an internship
at Google.
But so they have that discipline,
they have those foundations
in order to be successful,
to be able to get a job
or internship at Google.
So, then maybe in turn makes
college more affordable,
so basically the bottom
line of all this is it's all
interdependent.
Make sure that you're
doing good in school,
'cause to promise you it's
gonna work out for you
in the end.
- Yeah, Delisha what are
your thoughts on grades?
- I'm gonna go on a little
different direction,
but I will say that, I agree
that grades are important.
However, what I want
you all to understand,
and to hear me clearly.
Your SAT score is there any
test scores do not define you?
Your GPA does not define
because we all know that,
everyone wants different,
there's many situations
that may cause you to have
a low GPA.
There are situations
that may cause you that
to get the best score on the SAT or ACT,
you may not be a great test taker.
I wasn't the best test taker,
but what I did do was try my best.
And that's what I'm gonna
encourage you all to do,
is always ask yourself this question.
Am I trying my best number one,
number two, am I making sure
that this makes me happy?
And then number three,
am I betting on myself?
So those are the three
things that I want you to ask
yourself each time,
because at the end of the day,
especially in the world of cybersecurity,
we're not looking at your grades,
we're not looking at
your SAT or ACT scores.
What we're looking at is
how passionate are you?
How passionate are you
about wanting to rather save
the world in the cybersecurity space,
or save the world as software engineer,
or save the world by
creating beautiful art,
for the world to see.
The other thing that we're
looking at as well is,
are you dedicated?
Are you committed to being the best person
in the best version of yourself,
that you can be every single day?
Because again, it's really
important to not let any titles,
anybody, or anything defined
you because that's not,
what's important in life,
is it making you happy?
Is it something you're passionate about?
Is there a pathway that may
not be necessarily traditional
or linear that will get you
to where you need to go?
So that's kinda how I approach
and think about grading,
'cause I don't want
students to get bogged down
and worry that, oh, if I have a 2.5,
that I'm not good enough.
Or if I have a three point,
oh, I'm not good enough
and I need to have it 4.0,
you don't have to be perfect,
we're not looking for perfect,
we're looking for unique,
we're looking for you.
- Yeah, I appreciate that.
And I love that framework
that you introduced.
What about you Madison?
What are the roles of grades
have played with your,
and our test scores and how do you ...
what advice do you have for folks,
to put that in perspective?
- Yeah.
So I'm gonna just riffed
off a Delisha for a second.
I agree with both Ernest and Delisha,
grades are important.
They are direct reflection
most times of your drive
and work ethic.
But as Delisha mentioned,
there's unconventional ways
to get into that university,
or that school of your dreams.
While you maybe you don't have the grades,
or maybe you don't have
some other requirements.
Back at Howard actually
worked in admissions,
that's my work study.
And I found out about a
lot of processes that,
many people don't know about
such as something called
an appeals process.
I encourage everyone to call
their admissions department,
and let's say you do receive
a no from a university,
first and foremost and
there was only two letters.
So I know it may stink in the time being,
but again, it's only two letters,
there's possibilities and
ways to get that acceptance,
if you would call their
admissions department and just,
"Hey, do you guys have
an appeals process?"
And in that appeals process,
you essentially go
before a group of people,
and honestly plead your case,
'cause that sounds weird,(chuckle),
but you explain to them, you know,
"Hey, I was testing low in
this subject because of this,
my ACT score is low
because of this situation."
Really just explaining to them.
"Hey, I would love to
be at this university,
I would be an asset to this university,
I wanna be here."
And a lot of times those
university will hear you out.
And hopefully a lot of the times,
those denials turns into acceptances,
I just wanted to add
that in there,(chuckle).
- Yeah, that's super helpful.
You know, my takeaway hearing
y'all and this gels with
what I think too is, as all of y'all said,
grades are valuable,
they're valuable indicator,
they can correlate with your work ethic,
and your critical thinking
skills and all of that.
And if you get good grades and
if you get good test scores,
it will open up doors for you,
people will give you the
benefit of the doubt.
But with that said, if
you don't get them one,
I've seen the trend matters
more than the absolute.
So if you have some weaker grades,
but they improve over
time, that's a great thing.
In fact, that some ways shows,
something even more special
about your character,
that you can overcome
some of that adversity,
and that even if your
grades aren't where you want
are your standardized test scores,
as you just mentioned,
Madison and Delisha
mentioned this a lot as well,
that there's other ways to
show what you're capable of.
And frankly, the further
you get from college,
the further that people run
an index on other things,
other than those grades.
And I'd say the other way around,
we also all know students
who have straight A's,
but if they didn't or perfect
standardized test scores,
but if they didn't do the things,
that all of y'all have done,
when you're asked a lot of questions,
but, always be pushing yourself.
As Delisha mentioned,
am I taking a bet on myself,
and my stepping out of my comfort zone?
Am I willing to take some risks?
Am I willing to go talk to
people and risk getting rejected?
A lot of folks, I've seen a
lot of very capable people,
afraid to apply for an
opportunity for fear of rejection.
And the only way to guarantee
that you're gonna get rejected
is when you don't apply, (chuckle),
for something and you see
that over and over again.
One other question?
And then there's a ton that are coming up,
on social media right now.
If you were a young person
and you have this trade-off
between, there's something your parents,
or society is telling you should do,
because it's perceived
as a pragmatic profession
that you can make a good income,
versus something that you're
like, but my heart is there,
how do you navigate that?
Because at the end of the day,
you do have to pay the bills
and you do have to find a job,
but at the same time, you don't
wanna be miserable doing it.
And similarly, if people are like,
"Well, there's my dream school,
but it's even after financial
aid is gonna cost me
tens of thousands of dollars a year,
versus there's another
school that's pretty good,
but it's gonna be less."
How do you recommend
people navigate these types
of tensions?
These types of trade-offs,
I'll start with you, Ernest.
- Yeah, for sure.
And it's kind of funny,
'cause like my path
has been pretty linear,
like I love computer science
in high school did in college,
I'm a software engineer now, right?
My trade off,
or what I realized that
I'm very passionate about,
is actually doing work just like this,
talking to high school and
middle school students,
college students,
and making sure that they
have all the keys necessary,
to get them to the
school that they want to,
but then also gets to the
field that they want to,
bias towards the tech
industry reports, right.
I think the cool part
about the tech industry ,
is that, there is a lot of leniency,
I would say for you to
work on passive projects,
hobbies that you also wants to do,
but I would not be able to have right,
create codehouse,
and just so like,
we haven't talked too
much about codehouse,
but it's are a nonprofit that
has now raised $3 million
in just the last two years.
I would not have been able
to dedicate time like that,
if I wasn't working at
a place like Google,
where I had a lot of love and support
from not only my coworkers, my manager,
but the organization overall
to make sure I'm opening that
door and providing these
opportunities for other students,
right?
And so the cool thing
about the tech industry,
not only the job is a little bit lenient,
but the tech industry covers
every field imaginable
right now.
I literally have friends that,
you know, of course work
at the major tech firms,
but other people that
work in sports right,
at the Hawks or the Falcons
and if you're in Atlanta,
to with the Golden State Warriors.
So if you're into sports,
but you want to make a lot of
money right out of college,
you can go into tech and maybe
be one of their engineers
on the team.
So, there is a way it's for
you to try to balance it out,
and like my parents installed
on the (indistinct),
at a young age that I can do a lot,
and I can do anything I put my mind to.
So if I'm passionate about
something and I wanna merge it
with something that could
hopefully make me money,
or make college more affordable,
that there's a way to try
to make it all work out,
but that is why you need
to lean on a community,
reach out to people
who are in your spaces,
or in the space that you
desire to be in for advice,
and mentorship so that you
can learn from their failures,
their successes.
So you could try to make
a path for yourself,
one of the first things I
always have college students do,
is make a five-year plan.
This is a plan that doesn't
have to be set in stone,
it's not like this is it,
this is what we're
gonna do for us in life,
but it's good to have this is theme
with everything I say,
you're making a foundation for yourself.
So you have a general guidance
of what you want to do.
And I made my five-year
plans after talking to,
a ton of engineers at
Google, Microsoft, Twitter,
all these other companies
teach people who got their
PhD in computer science,
and now even people in
the nonprofit space,
because I'm trying to still figure out,
what exactly I wanted to do.
And if it wasn't for my
community around me supporting me
and helping provide guidance to me,
I think I would be walking
aimlessly, (chuckle)
so don't be shy to ask people questions.
And now that you all are listening to us,
hopefully some of you
guys have LinkedIn's,
I better see some LinkedIn
requests on for me,
and the other two (indistinct) as well.
- Well, thanks for that.
What about you, Madison?
What advice would you have?
- Hmm, I have tons,(laughs),
tons of advice.
I would say for college
students currently,
I would say that don't be
afraid to be multifaceted.
There's a world and a way to
merge all of the things that
you love into one, whether
it be simultaneously,
one at a time, there's
opportunity and space to do so.
And I would also say
it's okay to not know,
what you're doing.
Totally, totally, okay.
I think in this age of social media,
and almost the instant
gratification culture,
it's almost a pressure
to know all the time.
Like, hey, yeah, I know how to do that,
or yeah, I know what's going on,
or yeah, like I'm gonna
do this and do that.
But oftentimes we don't know, (laughs),
so I would say, as I said, previously,
asking questions and grabbing advice,
whether not saying
there's gonna a, you know,
all mighty knowing person
that is gonna pave your path,
there you go, pave your way to success,
but there's gonna be
individuals who add bricks
to that road,
and that's gonna help you essentially
get to where you need to be.
- Yeah, Delisha.
- Yeah, similar to what
Madison was saying,
you know, none of us are (indistinct),
so don't be afraid to
lean into other things
that you're passionate about,
and use that as your stepping stone.
So you wanna think of
whatever your current job,
or career is that you end
into for the beginning,
as a stepping stone.
Utilize that time that you have to
build on those passion projects,
start training after work,
start building out different projects,
whether it's an art project or
whether it's a coding project
and you're learning how to code,
or if you're trying to
learn cybersecurity,
and you wanna check out
Cyber Start America,
and possibly earn
scholarships for college,
just by playing a fun
cybersecurity game, whatever it is,
just utilize the resources that you have,
to get you to where you wanna go.
Because again, you don't have
to stay where you are forever
to whether it's a job at
Starbucks or a target,
or once you graduate from college,
and you get your first
real job out of college,
use that as a stepping stone,
don't look at it as, man I
have to stay here forever.
You don't just use it again
as the stepping stone,
as we are kinda stated
those building blocks,
and as Ernest said,
use it as a foundation to
leap frog into the career
that you want to be in,
and to create a path for yourself,
where you see success and happiness.
- Yeah, and maybe one last question,
this has been super hot,
I could talk to y'all for hours.
We're getting a couple
of questions about people
who I think are a little bit
unsure about college itself.
Going back to our original title,
Is College Right For Me?
(indistinct) say,
"I feel like college really isn't for me,
what career paths can I go into
and pursue without having to
do college?"
We have, Ruslana saying, "My
big problem is not knowing
enough about college, how to
navigate all of this stuff."
You know, what would you
say to these students,
who seem to be a little bit on the fence?
One, do they have to go to college?
Are there reasonable paths if
college isn't right for them,
but also how would you
have them think about that?
And maybe college is right for them.
I would take it in any order,
let's start with you Madison.
- Yeah, so I can say first and foremost,
no college isn't for
everyone and that's okay.
It's really, okay.
There's especially now
with us working from home,
and things being so readily available
within our home spaces,
there's training programs,
there's a lot offered through
Google as well as LinkedIn
and ways you can learn
tangible skills and get the,
I guess the almost the validation
that college does provide
in different means.
So, I do LinkedIn learning all the time,
and I learn new things, get certificates,
and they're able to build
up my resume in that way.
So just because, you know,
college is something that's,
so I guess, ingrained
within our society, psyche,
you don't necessarily have to do college,
if you don't believe it's for you.
Because at the end of the day,
if you go into something
that isn't for you,
you're gonna end up just
not wanting to do it.
And that is time, money spent
and things of that sort,
where you could amend
kinda focusing in things
where you do like,
but I will say college does
provide a lot of perspective,
not only in education,
but I learned a lot about
people and personalities,
and ways to work with people
and gain skills in that area,
which then helped me in my post career,
I learned a lot about going
to school out of state,
I learned about different
cultures and things that also
aided in my education and
aided me writing papers,
and aided me learning new history
to figure some things out.
So I would say now college
isn't for everyone,
but I do see benefits in going.
- Yeah, thanks for that.
What about you Delisha?
What would you say to these folks,
who might be a little bit on the fence?
- Yeah, college isn't
the end all for y'all.
And you can also look
at it from a sense of,
there are other unique ways
where you'll still get the knowledge,
people may call it college,
some people may call it trade school,
but there's different pathways alternative
that you can take.
Like Madison stated there
are training programs,
where you'll still learn the skills,
but it's not like a traditional college.
You have a community college
route or your tech local tech
schools where you're
able to learn a trade,
whether it's to become
a HVAC or AC technician,
a mechanic, we always need
someone to work on our cars,
construction, we always
need something built houses,
schools, hospitals, all the way to tech.
I'm sure, Ernest is gonna
talk to this as well,
but tech and cybersecurity is huge,
and there are a ton of
people who look like you,
who look like me, who are
from various walks of life,
who are 16 year olds,
who are 60 year olds,
whether you're new to
discovering and figuring out
what you want to do,
or you're someone who wants to transition,
and you're like, "I
wanna change my career,
I wanna change my job,
I want something different,
I want something new."
There's always an opportunity
through certifications.
And those are everywhere,
they're endless online,
whether it's through a Google,
rather it's through a SANS Institute,
whether it's through a
COSIA, Udemy, whomever,
there are opportunities
for you to gain skills,
and educate yourself without
going that traditional route
of a on campus or a traditional college.
And there are also other colleges
out there like my college,
where you have that
flexibility to be yourself,
and it's not in that
traditional structure.
You pretty much build your schedule,
you're able to work on your own time,
and you have the
opportunity to not only gain
hands-on skills without the fluff,
but once you graduate, you're
actually able to step into
a career that is fulfilling, fun,
and again, you get to save the world.
So, why wouldn't you want
to take a chance on that?
- Absolutely, and Ernest your advice.
- Yeah, so this question is a good one.
I'm gonna take my Google hat off,
'cause I know I've been a great
recruiter for Google today.
Oh, this question comes up a lot recently,
especially since like most
tech companies actually
took off their requirement
for a college level degree
in order to apply for
entry level positions.
So right now you don't
need to go to college
to get a job at Google.
I'm gonna put a big asterisk there though,
because if you can't go to college,
or if you're on the fence please just try.
If you're able to (indistinct) afford it,
go to the place that's
most affordable because
getting some kind of formal education,
does open doors for you.
I let say, I'm a computer scientist,
you know, I'm a software engineer,
I was pick a numbers,
when I got to Google,
Google reviewed 2
million around the world,
resumes for applications,
2 million, right?
So on that, just think of how
many were college educated
versus non-college educated here,
different kind of requirements.
There's a lot of competition in the world,
I don't say that to scary,
'cause if I was even
going to Google trust,
the everyone listening to
this call can also land a job
at Google, right?
I say that to say that, whether
organizations realize it,
or not there is some biases
towards people getting some
sort of formal education.
So there's so many different
ways to get formal education,
Delisha (indistinct),
certificates, training programs,
community college.
If you guys don't know, community
causes a great opportunity
where you can for most
places go to a school local
in your community and
get an associates degree
for little to no money at all.
And there's a lot of scholarships
to get to community college.
And then a lot of those
colleges have programs
would then transition to state schools
in the same state that you're in.
So like for Madison and I, we
had Middlesex County College,
a lot of our classmates went there,
and then transition over
to Rutgers University.
That's a great way to
still get formal education,
at less of a cost rather than paying for
Rutgers for 40 years.
That on top of doing
things like work study,
where you actually can't get
paid during the school year
to do a job,
having some role in at
the university or college,
that you attend on top of
maybe even being an RA,
RAs normally get free housing
for other institution,
doing research, if you come
into the tech industry,
there's a lot of schools that do research.
I was in research at Morehouse
and I was getting cheque
every month just to do
research on computer science.
So there's different ways
to make college affordable,
so I always strive to tell
students if you can afford it,
if you can make it happen,
please go to college,
because it's gonna help set you up
for the rest of the things in your life.
Anyway, so that's my advice
on it right now, (chuckle).
- Yeah, no, thanks all of
y'all for giving very honest,
and I think authentic answers,
which everyone really wants.
You know, I'll get my last few
cents on that last question.
I agree with everything,
that all of y'all said
there are other pathways,
and there's increasingly in
the past the other pathways,
people might've said
trade school and whatever.
And even those can be higher
compensating than people
recognize.
I once spoke at the National
Electrician Association,
and you can get an
apprenticeship after doing some
intro courses.
And then once you're done
with the apprenticeship,
you can be making six figures.
So, there could be very
good careers in the trades,
but as many of you all
alluded to many of the jobs
that we associate with college degrees,
like becoming a software engineer,
or working in cybersecurity,
there now might be alternative pathways,
Google and others have
certification mechanisms,
where that type of thing can happen.
But with that said, and I
think Ernest, you alluded to,
I think everyone alluded to this,
that it's still where
society is right now.
College tends to be the
most likely pathway,
and I just reflected people
who had a little bit of time
to reflect on their 20s,
and pretty much anyone who
went to college and finished,
does not regret it.
They don't say, "I wish I didn't go."
I do know folks who might've
started and didn't finish,
and then there might be some regrets.
And so I think maybe
the narrative might be,
it isn't college or bust,
it is really dig deep,
and I'm kinda connect some
dots with what all of you said,
what you care about, what you
love and what's sustainable?
You can't do anything even for four years,
if you don't at least reasonably enjoy it.
But, and then what's
sustainable financially time?
If you need to work
while you're in college,
but then try to put your
head down and get that done,
and probably will open doors for you.
But for whatever reason, if it
doesn't work out financially,
if that doesn't work out in any other way,
I always say, there's no right decision,
it's all about making the decision, right?
And we just talked about
the straight A student,
who might not get opportunities,
because they might become complacent,
or not wanna take risks,
there could be people with PhDs,
who don't reach their potential,
because they don't take risks.
And there could be people
who didn't go to college,
but they're always working,
they're always putting themselves
out of their comfort zone.
They're talking,
asking a lot of questions
they're being entrepreneurial,
and they can do just great.
So no simple answers to all of this,
but this was a fun beginning
to the conversation.
Thank you all for joining this,
and I hope we can do
something like this again.
- Yes, thanks so much for (indistinct).
- Thanks of having us.
- I would love to,(chuckle).
- Yeah.
- Sounds good, thanks everyone.
(popping sound)